alors après on peut aussi se poser
quelques questions sérieuses parce que
cette organe des électeurs du Front
national mais on a déjà tout essayé sauf
le FN c'est c'est dans mon frigo il y
avait plus rien alors j'ai bouffé le bac
à légumes
et maintenant j'accueille gaz par Proust
pour elle et la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fête
là je suis tellement content que je
pourrais te faire l'apologie littéraire
de Télé 7 jours
je suis un peu gêné d'habitude je finis
par les bonnes nouvelles mais parce que
des fois c'est
c'est rare
parce que des fois il y a il y a des
événements comme ça tu sais on les
attend ah oui et tu dis ça ça va pas
venir et je sais que tous les Français
partagent cette joie et je suis sûr
qu'ils ont tous pris un jour de congé
quand ils ont appris la nouvelle c'est
confirmé Nicolas est innocent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bolchevik Félix
parce que tout arrêter de fonctionner
puis le putsch de l'homme qui faisait la
pluie et le cracher ça ça allait plus
moi je savais qu'il avait rien faire
c'était pas possible un mec de sa classe
ça pudeur Sarko c'est un chat noir il
allait pas escroquer la momie princesse
de la laque en tirée de là c'est pas
c'est pas possible et quand bien même
quand bien même il y aurait du blé à la
bête en cours hey je veux dire il a
quand même sorti de Colombie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas partisan non non la
gauche depuis un an et demi elle a fait
des trucs vachement bien aussi elle a
perdu toutes les élections
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est branle-bas de combat les
brainstorming à Morano Lefebvre ont
repris des abonnements bibliothèque
municipales
Balkany est allé acheter du ciment et un
baril vide pour couler Fillon dedans
enfin ça va être parce que Fillon en ce
moment il est un peu un peu fais tout à
l'envers c'est parce que la procédure
habituelle en politique c'est quoi tu
dis que tu vas être candidat à la
présidentielle ensuite tu rassemble ta
famille politique et après tu raccords
un peu les voix du FN au second tour
voilà lui non GPS politique détraqué
d'abord il gratte du côté du FN ensuite
il divise sa famille politique et la fin
il dit que les candidats
[Musique]
le mec qui vient d'inventer le Moonwalk
politique
bon politique toujours Brignoles
cantonale explosive le PS n'est pas au
deuxième tour et le FN fait plus de 40%.
alors la question que tout le monde se
pose mais qui se cache derrière les
électeurs du PS
réponse tout de suite dans enquête
exclure
bonjour je suis Gaspard de la
proustellière
il se dit socialiste ils s'engagent pas
ce soir enquête excluante a voulu en
savoir plus sur ces militants dont les
élus ne dépassent plus le premier tour
de scrutin
Brignoles d'un côté la garrigue les
oliviers les petites gens qui vous
accueillent à coup d'eux alors il y a
trop d'étrangers mais Brignoles c'est
aussi un visage plus sombre
ce sont aussi les associations de
quartier l'engagement bénévole la
défense des citoyens bref le socialisme
ces gens qui se réclament d'un homme
nommé désir sans sucre un nuage de lait
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr madame un peu de sympathie
ces gens là on les a rencontrés dans un
lieu qu'ils appellent une Asos structure
étonnante car elle ne possède pas de but
lucratif
comme dans tous les groupuscules
radicaux on exalte le sang représenté
par cette affiche d'une main serrant une
rose on leur fait remarquer que c'est
une image qui rappelle les heures
sombres de l'histoire c'est à dire la
vente du muguet le 1er mai
sur deux il répond ah bon
tous nos témoins ont eu le courage de
répondre à un visage découvert c'était
Gaspard de la proustellière en
collaboration avec l'agence caca works
et flakoslip
bref alors après on peut aussi se poser
quelques questions sérieuses parce que
cette rengaine des électeurs du Front
national mais on a déjà tout essayé sauf
le FN c'est c'est dans mon frigo il y
avait plus rien alors j'ai bouffé le bac
à légumes
Assemblée nationale alors un député
imite une poule lors de la prise de
parole d'une collègue franchement c'est
pas plus indécent que lorsque les
députés écoutent héros en imitant un
poulpe mort
alors et puis on a une explication en
fait le député ne se moquait pas de
l'autre député il était juste en train
de traduire pour Christian Jacob
[Applaudissements]
école un professeur en garde à vue pour
image pédophile si on commence à
stigmatiser des profs qui s'intéressent
vraiment aux élèves
vacances je me disais en ce moment là
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui trouve tout
ça Lampedusa
je suis allé sur le site de cette île il
y a pas grand chose à faire
en termes d'hôtellerie il y a qu'un seul
hôtel 4 étoiles et encore le wifi est en
supplément
non c'est vrai alors au fond vous savez
c'est des sujets un peu délicats moi ce
qui me frappe chez les clandestins c'est
pas tant leur socle de connaissance
assez bancales en natation
[Musique]
mais leur manque d'exigence oui quand tu
vois ce qu'il y a là-bas le problème
c'est pas d'accueillir toute la misère
du monde mais au moins un peu de son
ambition c'est tout si je peux passer un
message enfin voilà divers une chamelle
a été volée dans un parc animalier de
l'Oise ça sent la voiture bélier halal
sport Paris va accueillir les Gay Games
2018 bon c'était limite il paraît que
tous ces jouets lors du grand oral
si on peut
c'est un bel événement pour la télé à
part les épreuves de lutte qu'il faudra
passer en crypté
alors bonne nouvelle oui le Nobel de
physique a été décerné à François
Englert et
pour la découverte du boson de X
très important très très important parce
que tu vois sans ça au quotidien on
pourrait pas expliquer la brisure de
l'interaction unifiée électro faible en
deux interactions par l'intermédiaire du
mécanisme de broute Englert x again
buranique qui bluff donc j'ai envie de
dire faites du buzz au boson alors
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu